once you made the movie kings of comedy
and all that stuff
you started to get offers to do other
movies well i was i had offers before
the kings
right and what the kings did for me it
broadened my horizon
whites now got really more in tune my
audience was like 80 20.
yeah these whites they don't know what's
going on well they always relax
hollywood the last to catch on but if
you look at all the great
comedians you know all of them started
like richard pryor
you know red fox sam kinderson right you
know they get they got tuned into them
uh uh late because they say they're hard
they're raunchy
meanwhile they were the cutting edge
they were the guys who were on the front
everybody else
everybody working on image trying to be
politically correct right
i like so many people so many comedians
but flip
wilson i i dug flip wilson
as a man because he was so secure with
himself he never
felt self-pity and i took a page out of
his notebook
you know red fox red skelton
i had somebody everybody ask me who i
really dug
i took a mom's maybelline oh yeah who
was uh very
cheated under she was the funniest oh
she was one of the funniest comedians
red fox used to say that all the time
when uh they would be in the clubs
i don't know what was that don't stay up
there yeah i used to sit and listen to
our records
yeah yeah right she was real good okay
nobody followed you might as well go
home
so so let me ask you this one of the
things you started doing
right which is amazing to me is you had
no stand-up club when you started your
career you were a poor man
you used to go in a park sure did and
start to do your stand-up in the park
on the trains in chicago you would stand
in a train
yeah tell me how that works like you
would you would go in the train in a
subway
and you would stand there to cart and
you'd say ladies and gentlemen do some
comedy i will come up in the morning i
will
watch the news and see what was ever
happening in the city yeah you know
because routine together
you know because chicago is you know a
city of neighborhoods right right
i'm telling you i made good money a lot
of people call me an idiot
because i stopped doing it because i
felt like i was begging
right i wanted to be legitimized yeah i
wanted the club to call my damn
how much money could you make oh wow
be honest with you i made maybe
500 cash cash wow and it got to the
point where they knew me
you know they were looking that's the
guy that's a guy you know when i come
from car to car they knew me right
and i so you would look at that you
would this is fascinating to me you
would look in the newspaper you would
see what was going on
and then you'd go into the subway you
have a routine for the train and
i wouldn't freelance that's a tough
crowd our freelancer well no wonder
you're so talented i mean if you could
do that on a subway yeah
an audience that's paid to be
entertained is easy all the parks was uh
a gym
yeah i would do the parks on saturday
mornings and stuff you know
um and everybody playing softball and
stuff
and i would just commentate i would just
commentate right you know you have to
split with a club on it oh man i had it
made
how many years did that go on about four
and a half five years
wow and then i then i started doing
funerals
no i'm serious well this happened that
you what your grandfather died my
grandfather died
and he was like the mayor and uh we
lived over the church he was a big
deacon
and when he passed at the funeral
everybody was it was just so
sad and i just got up and i started
mimicking my grandfather
i said this is what i this is what i
remember my grandfather
and i used to do his voice and i did his
walk and i was told some stories
about what i remembered of my
grandfather you mimicked
another word you you did a a comedy
routine
and the place went crazy it went crazy
and so from this time
you got hired everybody started calling
me after that man my cousin died man you
stopped by the house and you had another
cut you do a couple of routines right
but you know what that did not come from
the heart yeah right
i couldn't i didn't do that because i
felt like a hypocrite you know what i
mean
exactly but my grandfather that came
naturally that was just something that i
just spontaneous did